so during the home stretch of the 2020
election President Trump was rocked by
one the worst presidential campaigns in
modern history you're saying this that's
your claim they ran effectively one of
the worst presidential campaigns in
modern history with star con contrast to
his 2016 the president himself I think
did a wonderful job leading the country
he had a vision but he frankly was let
down by bad Personnel that got inside
the west wing and never should have
Navarro told the Washington examiner
Monday at a cocktail and press event for
his new book taking back Trump's why we
lost the White House and then you
continue but in navarre's mind the
election should have been a landslide
that they would have likely eclipsed any
potential fraud campaign uh ineptness uh
morphed Trump's Showdown with Biden into
something far closer than it otherwise
would have been and then you continue to
talk about you know the West Wing
dumpster he has a long lamented that the
Trump Administration was stacked with
poor personal choices such as former
chief economic advisor Gary Cohen former
treasury secretary Steve
mnuchin and former Chief of Staff John
Kelly
and then last but not least there was
one man in particular whose involvement
particularly PIV Navarro Trump's
son-in-law Jared Kushner in 2016 we were
significantly outspent by but the money
was used wisely and in 2020 we had
plenty of money but Kushner Burton like
monkey with a flamethrower and when push
came to shove in final six weeks of the
campaign we ran out of money Navara said
there were young kids over there making
six figures and then when the pandemic
hit they didn't even work come to work
while Brad Pascal was the chief of the
floundering Trump campaign on paper
Navara dubs Kushner as the de facto
campaign manager responsible for much of
the campaign's chaos in his book slated
for release Tuesday he alleged that
Kushner frequently added points to the
polls and lied to the boss eventually
Navarro and his allies backed by Donald
Trump Jr concocted an unsuccessful coup
d'etat of sorts of oust Kushner from his
campaign perch according to the book The
Navara Kushner was part of a larger
problem in the White House
fueling much of Trump's woes was the
reapproachment with the traditional
Republicans the former president
pursuing pursued during his early White
House days so I mean this is a direct
call out of Kushner yeah okay yeah
direct call out this is a son-in-law
this is married to his daughter and this
is a guy that was on the cover of Time
Magazine family business you know all
the great things he's doing he's about
20 minutes from here yeah he is setting
up a a money fund and and leveraging his
experience such as it was in the White
House making a ton of money
Middle East maybe China
um and it was a business to him and look
if you talk about the campaign itself
I'll give you a couple of examples
Zuckerberg at Facebook
spent more money
in the Battleground states where this
election was settled then the Trump
campaign did think about that Zuckerberg
alone
spent more money
you talking about the 400 million
it's a bit more than that last time I
looked it was it was more than that more
like 800 million it's a bunch of money
and we we didn't
look you talked about me early on
running for office kind of the one
mistake I made I ran from mayor San
Diego 92 lost by any percentage point
maybe a percentage point and a half okay
the big mistake I made was I spent my
money early okay all I need had to do
was win that race was wait till the last
three to four weeks and spend my money
then when people were paying attention
we blew
10 10 million dollar Super Bowl ads for
60 seconds and when when the last
three to four weeks of the campaign we
had to pull ads from the Battleground
States and Biden outspent Us in the
Battleground States on ads when when we
outraged them and this this shouldn't
happen but the bigger problem Patrick
was the messaging itself you know the
message should have been
tough on China
it should have been tough on China and I
had a beautiful one of the things I
learned it's like you know I go in there
and I'm kind of a Rube when I first get
there
and they try to bury me and it's that's
all chronicled in uh in my in Trump time
book where they they try to marginalize
me I've been on the campaign I've been
the top economic advisor and when I get
there
the the reince priebus the chief of
staff and kind of the Rhino Wing they
try to just bury me over in the EOB so
what I did was dig in and learn how how
power works in the White House and the
the instrument of power in the White
House is the executive order and
presidential memorandum and I learned
how to write those things
and
I I think I had more hands and more EOS
than any other person in the West Wing
when the when the dust settled but the
one that got away from me that would
have swung the election
and it should be passed today in
Congress was an executive order that
would have held communist China to
account for the virus it called for
investigating communist China's role in
the virus and estimating the costs
um of that virus on the U.S economy
demanding reparations and basically just
airing this whole thing out
and I got within a whisker of getting
the boss on board with that he liked it
initially but he got talked out of it by
the likes of Kushner at all
um who didn't want to rock the China
boat they thought oh it's like now we
can't do that now but that that would
have shifted the blame
for the pandemic from Trump's shoulders
which was there
unfairly
to where it belonged to come as China
and that one got away and that's to me
the ultimate failure
of the the Trump campaign we ran we
forgot who we were we were we're Mega
and we're tough on China we forgot that
and we lost so with the election coming
up Peter you've got the American people
were hurting on two sides one we were
hurting socially because we got the
virus we got you know vaccines people we
know were passing away uh that's real it
was very real very real but then we also
had economic impact you know we see what
happened to credit card debt that was
later bailed out by the uh by the by the
uh trillions dollars of printing money
and stimulus so you're saying at that
time just being tough on China would
have swung the election that seems like
a broad statement with a lot going on
with the American voters yeah okay let's
when was this let's put the date January
28 2020 you're very specific about that
when would you have implemented this
tough on China at what point was that
when you when they said no we're not
going to do this so we can kind of see
the mind and the ramp you're very
specific and you're very convincing show
us the ramp into the election from that
day okay let's let's first first make
the case that
in January 2020 Trump was a lock for
reelection at that point I think that
the strength of the economy I don't
think anybody with the people nobody
would know that we all remember this
the NBA player Mark Cuban on camera the
NHL panics and cancels it yeah 72 hours
in February it's probably a book someday
72 hours in February where life changed
for us prior to that 100 agreement yeah
and and and just a little side note
um I was in the Oval Office with the
president with Kudlow with mnuchin with
others Mulvaney
um in early February before all this
fell apart and they're they're going
like don't worry about the virus it's no
big deal we got it under control right
it's like there's only a couple of goals
there's only four cases and I'm thinking
dude you don't understand logarithmic
progression you know it's four today
eight tomorrow
um and
one of the problems we had was we we
didn't signal that we were taking the
virus
seriously early
and through the combination of you know
fauci became the voice of the
administration uh Trump became the guy
that the American people held
responsible for everybody dying and yeah
we did some great things I I got some
great tales in the book about getting
um his cotton swabs over from a plant in
Italy in three days after commandeering
uh Pentagon planes in the cooperation of
FedEx I mean we were like we did as well
as we can but but we didn't Market it
well so my point is that talk about the
first chapters of operation warp speed
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and my point is
that is that the virus
just just everybody blamed Trump okay
let's let's agree that the American
people blame Trump for the virus I think
that's for the for not handling the
virus well all right so that was the
problem we were dealing with the diet
the the the the the conversation about
the election
um and driven by CNN and MSNBC with
their body counts to a certain extent
Fox was that this is the major issue and
Trump's the blame I think that's was the
sentiment of the country and it's like
wait a minute it's like
we're doing a good job if we could get
that message out but more importantly
this isn't Trump's fall this is the a
virus from a lab in Wuhan that's being
hit so my thinking was that if we could
air that out that would that would
basically and we were going to drop the
report okay the preliminary report the
EO was written we dropped the
preliminary report in the first week in
October
and that report and it would be from a
group of very distinguished people you
know you look at the data it's on it
it's like there's no doubt that thing
came from the lab and that would have I
think
I think that would have
helped with that one issue it would have
changed changed the dialogue on that but
that one got away
you talked you talked about the the
number of people uh on the campaign
specifically Kushner when you're talking
about during that time in 2016 Brad
Pascal was the digital media director
and then I think in 2020 he became the
campaign manager yeah in 2016 I recall
him being a star everybody was talking
about look what a great job he did but
then you're criticizing them for 2020 on
what he did so what was different about
Brad in 2016 versus 2020 with a strategy
what per scale did well was handled
digital media he wasn't running a
campaign mind you okay running a
campaign
is a very complex task across 50 states
I mean you got to do all sorts of stuff
and what he did was one
important bucket out of a hundred
and
the the two worst mistakes that parscale
made it was the same mistake in a way
was when he got on 60 minutes after the
2016 election and effectively not only
claim credit for the win you know was
him not Trump that won the election
because of his genius
but he also revealed that he had
recruited uh Facebook
employees and I think Twitter employees
actually work inside the campaign to
help them managing their messages on the
social welfare platforms okay what did
that do that was like a wake up I write
about this in in the in Trump time but
that's like a wake-up call to Silicon
Valley it's like Zuckerberg's getting
hate mail dorsey's getting ahead now how
could you lie in bed and make a bunch of
money from Trump and Par scale basically
planted the seeds of Zuckerberg's
counter-offensive in the 2020 campaign
look Brad
Brad's a good guy he's a nice guy but
he's a
Geeks
he sits yeah he's again it's like when
the pandemic hit it was a blessing for
him because oh he could go back to what
he did in 2016. they're very important
what what what he did in 2016 was
sitting in San Antonio most of the time
in front of his computer and like this
time when the pandemic hit he was down
here in Miami
significantly richer would like a big
boat and seven cars he didn't even come
very often up to Arlington to the
campaign you can't do that look look
it's like I the analogy I used was like
putting a plate a champion Place kicker
in it quarterback okay he was a great
place kicker in 2016. okay he could hit
the uprights from 60 yards
in 2020 you can't put him in the Super
Bowl that's the Super Bowl guys that's
the Super Bowl he wasn't Tom Brady so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
foreign
[Music]